Here's a case study
of five devices.
Once again, I
really encourage you
to see who the researchers
are in the visual index
at the end of this material.
This is pretty wonderful stuff.
So we have five devices,
three on the right
and two on the left.
Notice the composition-- not
boringly lined up in a row.
So this image was taken in
let's call it the default mode,
as most of the others.
So to remind you, this
is with reflected light
coming from below the glass.
The light bounces off
the device and is read
by the sensor below, again.
Pretty standard setting
on your flatbed scanner,
as if you were
scanning a document.
Now look what
happens when we use
transmitted light, that
is, light from above,
where the information is
still captured from beneath.
You'll see that the left two
are just rectangles of black.
And that's because, of
course, that the light
is prevented from
being transmitted
through the solid silicon chip.
No light is reaching the sensor.
Whereas the others on the
right are showing some detail,
since they are
somewhat transparent.
Remember, the sensor
is beneath the glass.
So as we zoom in, the
slides on the right
show some pretty
interesting detail--
detail that we would not
see with reflected light.
You might want to
pause the video here
to see the differences.
The luxury here is
having the ability
to transmit light
through your sample.
My flatbed scanner has a
light source in the cover.
I set my scanner in the
transmitted light mode,
as if we were scanning film
or other transparent material.
But you should play around
with your own setups.
For example, here I just opened
the cover of the scanner.
This sitting in
the scanner is set
to scan with reflected light.
This is one of those examples
when experimenting can give us
an unusual result-- something
new and possibly useful.
OK.
Let's take a look at
biological growth in a Petri
dish for another case study.
This is showing E. coli
growing under four conditions.
I put the Petri
dish on the scanner,
and once again use the
default reflected light.
Capture it at a pretty high
resolution, around 400 megs
for the whole image.
Looks good.
But as we zoom in, we're
getting some dust and dirt
on the surface of
the Petri dish.
I'm not happy about that.
So I decided to try
transmitted light,
as we just saw before in
our previous case study.
My scanner, remember, has a
light source in its cover,
giving me transmitted
light, that
is a light coming from above.
Using this transmitted
light approach
make sense for bacterial
and biological growth
in Petri dishes.
If you don't have a scanner
that has the light in its cover,
then you might have some
luck with reflected light.
But I wanted to make a
particular point here.
Here, I'm using a mobile phone
camera, making a picture that
is pretty OK, just
quickly showing what's
going on here in the
Petri dish, but compared
to this high-resolution scanned
image using transmitted light,
and it's a whole
different world.
I'm overlapping
here the phone image
over the transmitted
scanned image
so that you can see the
important point here.
The phone image is
considerably smaller
in terms of its file size,
so that when we zoom in
closely on the computer screen
with each of these images
we see pretty significant
differences in resolution.
In this scanned image
of about 400 megs,
you can see remarkable detail
as we move into the image.
But the phone image,
well, let's just
say is not totally remarkable.
So it depends on what you'll
be using these images for.
I really do want
to encourage you
to get the very best image you
can from the very beginning.
It's the difference between
spending one minute on an image
and six minutes, let's say.
My hope is that you see that
spending the additional five
minutes is pretty
much worth the time.
Don't you think?